[Music]
it's that time again Sony has unveiled
the ps+ essential games for January 2024
the following games will release on the
first Tuesday of the year that's January
2nd and this month we have a ratty
stealth outing an action RPG and a
supernatural vampire hunt please leave
me a like and maybe a comment to help me
please the YouTube Gods thank you kindly
here we go first up on the PS5 is a
plague Tale requium the sequel to a
plague tale innocence we got on PS plus
a year or two back in this stealth
focused action game we follow siblings
Amia and Hugo making their way through
France as a dark plague covers the land
and if you haven't noticed there's rats
so many rats as our heroes are quite
diminutive combat is mainly focused
around avoidance and misdirection to
move guards out of our path and
utilizing swarms of rats thanks to
Hugo's mysterious Powers puzzles are
everywhere usually keeping fires burning
to hold off the impending swarms and and
carefully strategizing to remain unseen
in dire moments essentially if you
enjoyed a plague tale requium you'll
enjoy this one too everything has been
improved it's bigger it's better it's
more brutal and there's so many more
rats Metacritic says 82% which is very
impressive next we have an action
adventure game from the studio that
brought us the brilliant guacamelee this
is nobody Saves the World everything has
been overrun by beasts and fungus and
our last hope to survive is you nobody
very blandl looking nobody we then fight
through the minions of Hell in Dungeon
crawling RPG style to save the day and
here's the great part the wand we
possess can switch the holder into
different forms 18 in total including
magicians rats and Dragons each of those
having different abilities like a
bodybuilder pushing his weights there's
a horse that can run very fast and even
a necromancer shape-shifting quickly
becomes the car mechanic to overcome
increasingly challenging scen scenarios
and that's not it each skill we unlock
in the progression tree can be applied
to other character forms creating your
own unique play style at a basic level
you'll give the knights Shield to more
vulnerable characters or if you prefer
give Rockets to a rat or toxic waste to
that rushing horse getting creative with
options opens up possibilities and
constantly revamps the gameplay nobody
Saves the World can be played Solo or
online in Co-op one year ago this was an
XBox exclusive for 3 months and now it's
dropping on ps+ essential will you give
it a go game three is evil West on both
PS4 and PS5 a third person shooter in
which we play as Jesse a vampire hunter
set in the American frontier we must
Purge the evil and work our way towards
vampiric boss fights this means weapons
are key and evil West is packed with
them from your trusty six shooter to
augmented electrified rifles and melee
is actively promoted too your fists of
Steel can res resemble Wolverine's claws
if you so desire there's about 14 hours
of content here with reviewers saying
things get awfully monotonous but if you
want to run through hords of vampire
minions with fun and unique weapons then
evil West is happy to oblige average
review score 7 out of 10 so that's our
month what floats your boat nobody Saves
the World in Co-op Is My Jam please
share your opinions in the comments I'm
Adam you're awesome it's been a pleasure
happy New Year see
[Music]
[Applause]
you
to